happy Halloween there reject nation
that's so early in the morning we got a
treat this morning a trailer for Jumanji
and the next level otherwise known as
Jumanji for that's right I'm one of the
people who can sit through a movie I've
never seen yeah we might do a livestream
later on today talking about her
favorite Halloween movies subscribe hit
that notification buff you haven't done
so already I wanted to say thank you to
everyone who has followed us and start
us at this month over there would you 30
second reaction reviews for films TV
shows and or trailers we post daily and
we post a lot about things we don't
cover on YouTube and if we are gonna do
a review usually our opinion goes there
first if you want to get really access
to that plenty of influencers youtubers
people of you know what was the people
of color boys why people anyway let's
watch this trailer I love the first
trailer so let's go into this
[Music]
[Music]
did you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa oh cool huh really
that makes a big up on Stranger Tides
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they spoil that I'm at that point of
usually with roles like this especially
with like Dwayne Johnson and Kevin Hart
that if they're going to be taking on
the personalities like a Dane DeVito and
Danny Glover
usually in the position if I want to be
more than an impression I wanted to I
want it to be like a real character
you know something about to stuff or I
don't really even care if they like
going to full-blown characters is so
funny in these trailers this is in the
car and they're all freaking out and he
still it's got the same cadence the same
kind of deliveries and kind of trine is
even we're not gonna make it hyper blown
out or anything is pretty freakin funny
Jumanji welcome to the jungle I I was
like alright I'm looking forward to that
I guess and watched it and it was okay
the announcement of this sequel hasn't
really excited me but every time I
watched the trailer for the first one
for this for this installment it's like
what he meant it's one of the best is
consistently hilarious to me every time
I watch it it is so damn funny watching
a little bit more jokes here
I love how actually in this poster
Bethenny the horse it's easily there are
a lot more self-aware this time around
just something that's something that's
really necessary if you're gonna do this
equal to you know and I love that about
it yeah weirdly I I really like that
first trailer I agree with you I think
it's one of the most memorable and the
most fun and surprising trailers of the
year actually didn't care that much for
this particular trailer just because I
[ __ ] the first one actually had
finesse in this one recapped that one in
the first half and then kind of very
slapdash leader sort of show it a bunch
more set pieces and elements and stuff I
mean like you know I was already sold on
this movie from the first trailers and
the stakes are low to me the prospect of
other games getting bigger the rules are
changing we might not all make it out
even though I don't expect that to be
true it seems like you know it's some
cool stay
to add that's fair I guess what I would
have liked is a look at Aquafina or any
of the other aspects of I feel like this
trailer could have been an opportunity
to showcase some other aspects of the
movie and they just did kind of the same
thing but with less organization where
it's like let's show a bunch of gags of
the main cast and so for Sun roof for me
it still worked on it so yeah there we
go and I love it I'm so much more
excited for this movie than I was for
welcome to the jungle I don't know if
isn't let me down which is great
trailers I've heard some fun theories
about Nick Jonas is a seaplane character
okay that could be Spencer and it's just
in there or the other joke is that
Spencer never actually went to the game
you went out to get like a soda or
something on the ground and then part I
missed you guys I've been trying to hang
out with oh yeah man I thought you
abandoned me yeah and then we got like a
look at the I was feeling like the next
level of things yeah in the snow
yeah the snow and then he's talking to
torment from Game of Thrones which was
awesome yeah whoo the whole thing with
Jack Black Bethany going back to me out
of the switch yeah I kind of wish the
trailer didn't reveal that moment yeah
I'm like all about lore and plot twists
too much well I think they already gave
us the horse and then there yeah
uncovers the horse just as they've
surprised us with the horse in the
trailer yeah it's like I wouldn't have
minded like a lot of bits that hone in
on like interacting with Bethany the
horse you know or or what they could do
with that
maybe attempting at the they'll be
avatar switching throughout the VA which
gonna be fun like personalities switch
up throughout the movie that would be
nice I mean III yeah I could have maybe
used either some more variety in that
department or maybe just some more
hinted story there's something because I
feel like they filled this trailer
mostly with like character hijinks that
are familiar to the last movie yeah and
I'm still kind of in the dark as to like
what's the actual rust of the movie
gonna be about except for you know
finding Spencer hey I wanted to watch
this in this Halloween
Jumanji the next level that put out some
Halloween video yesterday that we just
found so this is only a minute long
let's check it out I've never seen a
group of kids dressed like the cast of
Jumanji it's bite sized tiny mini like
you maybe makes a money decorations
around here hey kids
the way the rock Johnson
oh we did watch the trailer today is
tomorrow - that's funny the rock
definitely does not live there no that's
just not can I be the rice tractor like
this like you know sensible suburban and
this you know little ad for the trailer
for Jumanji I like that they bothered to
be like you're dressed like Jumanji yeah
we're not supposed to that is a funny
bit yeah this is a what like the 4th the
film they're doing together yeah they've
gotten so much mileage out of mangy
central audience he was in Hobbs and
sobs and and yeah then we got this one
sorry for the big camp you know if you
haven't seen it by now that's on you
well anyway guys I'm just going here -
laughs that's all I care about
yeah all right guys well are you excited
for Jumanji the next level leave a
comment below you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell they get notified whenever we got a
video up make sure to download falls on
the Stardust app and be safe on a
Halloween that falls on a Thursday which
is also a workday and a school day so
you can't go partying too hard